allez on y va hormis chez l'espèce est
prêt à faire une interview première fois
d'accord pour mon premier souvenir qui
était dans la chambre s'était montée sur
une chaise que j'écoutais de la musique
et se faisait il était alors qu'elle a
besoin et qui vous ferait retrouver ça
complètement stupide un séisme ils en
ont vraiment là vous savez avec les
concertistes était pianiste julie à
quatre mains tous les noms j'avais un
professeur tapé sur les arrêts de avec
ma règle pour le solfège
sinon c'était ma grand mère m'a piano et
puis étudie tout le monde croit que je
sors du conservatoire en fait c'est pas
magique on suit équipe musicale d'abn 38
un bon pianiste est totalement trouvé un
bon très très mauvais tienne l'atria
vivre elle fait défaut alors oui mais
aussi le premier disque que thq sa série
charmed
le premier vise haut c'est une pochette
blanche et intitulé well as dû faire à
la maison quand même j'en ai en tout cas
l'intérieur l'as s'intéresse à d'abord
manqué au sol la première ci avait
quitté ses labours bas étaient blancs
parce que moi c'est très
le savoir parce que répondez vous
c'était c'est comme lire de la musique
sans connaître la partition quoi
première fois c'est au fus
j'avais un petit studio parce que très
très bien car ce n'est pas ce que je
vais moins 15 ans j'ai commencé à gagner
ma vie en écrivant des chansons ce qui
était quand même très particulier et
j'étais très très vite là c'est
indépendance et le même studio et voilà
le premier garçon le petit effet la
broye et ben écoute ça c'est une
expérience que j'ai pas eu lui en même
temps j'ai beaucoup de tendresse pour
pour les gens qui ont les meilleures
choses pas contre 1 sera pas content
qu'il y ait un truc fille ce vol je suis
incroyablement attirés par les genevois
peut pas avoir trouvé beau un mec
vraiment par exemple se trouve
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il ferait un
bon jour montré aucun tabou moral par
rapport à cela la première chanson que
j'ai écrite c'est vrai que c'est pour
bourvil excepté la girafe
ouais c'est ça la petite passe à un
sujet qu'il ya vraiment aidé à voir ce
que pour vous aussi dit non mais c'est
un type extraordinaire moi j'étais je
voulais l'actuel directeur artistique de
cellules hépatiques et qui s'occupait de
la place ne me souviens que c'était très
c'était une époque booster les jeunes
qui dès la loi il avait envie de faire
travailler déjà le look a pour but à 1
et au bout il ya été formidablement
r retrouve l'oeil sur un pat magee avait
agité et je sais par expérience en pour
vous parce que vous avez chanté moi
c'est pas du tout mon truc je
m'intéresse c'est les beatles et et mais
moi écrivez moi ça au contraire ça leur
va s'appuyer créances ont pour lui la
règle en pas chanter comme un truc
heurts survenus dans son bon droit mais
ça m'a permis d'y étudier au parc est ce
que t'as pas eu un complexe coiffe
vis-à-vis du rock and roll tu dis
toujours je fais pas du rock and roll
c'est la routine yousif l'air de dire
bon c'est pas complètement du
rock'n'roll est ce que t'as pas été est
ce que vraiment est passé à côté bonnes
élèves et tu serais pas assez dit ce
treuil pour être vraiment rien laisser à
l'intérieur ça se passe rien et je pense
que c'est plus une histoire à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur
je vis un handicap par rapport à ça
c'est parler dans les secteurs
ouais c'est prière très très sage pour
finalement wells et leurs bons gars et
bien habillé en soldat est entré à
l'intérieur c'est s'il ya un terreau
première production c'est vrai que
c'était dur et mexès
gisi c'est un allemand et un gros
canular sa femme a permis ça y est les
régions par la marée montante chez
c'était un petit peu celui des parisiens
qui a fait 1
ouais t'as ton animé et nous on s'est
dit on n'arrête pas de dire oui la
muraille qui a fait oublier intéressant
l'europe s'est faite pour les américains
c'est dur on a fait un an et demi elle
avait comme cela quand elle chantait si
la personne ne savait que c'était nous
comprend et donc les programmateurs de
radio ils ont dit voilà c'est là c'est
vraiment de la musique américaine et
bien non c'est un plaisir malgré un
break non c'est ça oui on a été pêché un
petit pour chanter en anglais est un
type qui en a vendu un ministre et après
il a tout perdu en faisant un 33 tours
s'appelait puzzle voilà si c'est quoi ce
foulard j'avais gagné je les unir deux
jours gagnant face à phoenix
je voulais faire un concerto avec un
groupe avec une guitare elle exprime une
basse et une batterie à l'heure et
rabeni et là j'en ai vendu 300 s'est dit
que le ou plus celle que je devais faire
par la suite on était dedans mais ses
termes pied extraordinaire je les écoute
des postes c'est une boucle son premier
drame dans ta vie c'est et quand le vrai
drame contre éclair de mon frère y était
celui ci m'a appris beaucoup de choses
réelles
la mamie s'appelant toile s'est suicidé
aussi oui c'est vrai ça c'est le premier
drame
c'est un ami d'enfance avec les faits
j'ai pas s'exciter maintenant ce qui est
cédée le pourquoi je crois que c'est une
histoire d'amour justement les rives ton
premier amour grande à moi mais moi j'ai
eu très peu d'amour ces derniers sont
premièrement oui je crois que c'est à
peu près le premier important et vous
avez rompu pourquoi tu sais que tu
ailles qu'il faut le demander
on lui a demandé ses pour comparer car
c'est comme si on me munitions ont fini
aux échos son 10e quand amour et
l'écouté je crois que je suis maintenant
conclut loire s'est pas franchement
annoncé la tam être fidèle
ouais assez
julien clerc nous a raconté que lui vont
compléter avec lui il est un peu dans
l'ombre et que toi au contraire cela
mise dans la lumière crois que c'est ça
en dehors de l'amour qu'elle entre vous
parce que c'est ça qui vous a réuni
ailier pour longtemps je sais pas tu
sais je crois que s'il suit très
difficile de dire pourquoi ça ça va d'un
couple après ça va plus je crois que
c'est très très difficile de faire
passer sa vie avec la même personne
salaire de normandie loin ça va quand sa
miraculeuse légère quand c'est dur à
certains de l'année ton premier succès
personnel
quant à chanter des chansons le premier
truc a vraiment marché de toit par toi
la vie du pianiste d'un groupe islamiste
ouais ça fait effectivement un coup ça a
été incroyable parce que tu es là je
sais pas je donne non plus non c'était
déjà
quatrième et cinquième album enfin à huy
ha vu plein de gens qui commençaient à
penser que l'auteur s'était compromis
toutes les chansons pour les autres
autre exemple les mêmes mondiaux ayant
j'arrête je fais des chansons plus
bonjour moi j'avais avant non à aucun
moment n'ont trouvé la carte et c'est
vrai n'ont pas mis le cheveu blanc s'en
souvient sans qu'elles aient non moi je
sais un bon dix mois on va voir ça doit
marquer un prêt qui veut avoir des comme
celle de paix 1980 oui dans un article
une interview de georges marc benamou
dans le quotidien de paris tu viens
d'avoir mon premier show leblanc et j'ai
journée tout un plat ouais vous savez
absolument parce qu'elle est arrivée